[Music]
what's up guys
so a few days ago beautiful people that
must be decided to make a quiz about my
favorite topic which is meat and so we
decided to ask you guys questions to see
whether or not you guys know a lot of
random things about me feel like I think
you guys are gonna do well cuz I'm
pretty open about everything that I like
and everything that I don't Mike I think
that there's gonna be some surprises
because I feel like sometimes people
think that I'm a lot more food than I
actually am I'm excited to see how you
guys did so let's go let's get started
all right what kind of guy do you think
curly is most into rich guys oh man
hairy guys well-groomed guys fashionable
guys I definitely like rich guys so if
you are rich and you're out there I'm
here for you
well-groomed guys I feel like I'm super
hairy so it's hard for me to be
well-groomed all the time so I don't
want to be the hairy one fashionable
guys there's only room for one in this
relationship so hairy guys oh wow you
guys picked fashionable guys I like a
guy who's just like in a jersey and like
sweatpants gray sweatpants
I like harried Isis there's something
really sexy about like chest hair arm
hair like hair I'm like we'll be in LA
traffic and I will see like five cars
down some do put their hairy arm out and
I'm like here you are I'm alert I love
it it's so sexy you know if you're born
with back here I'm not mad at you I'm
not going to be like it'll back here but
I'm I can give or take you have it cool
if you don't cool
I do like booty hair though would curly
rather wear a Selena outfit or a Beyonce
outfit Oh a Selena outfit for sure I had
one made custom-made for me
what are you wearing what am I wearing
Selena good job good work guys
oh this one's a tricky one which spice
girl is Curly's favorites ginger spice
sporty scary posh or baby Wow
I think it's a complete tie between
ginger and scary if I have to say which
one I'm most like like on maybe in life
I would have to say that I am like a
ginger spice actually I'm definitely
like a series by let's say Scary Spice
oh wow you guys said posh know partially
you're amazing and if you ever want to
be friends come up for dinner
I can make great barbecue chickens but I
was always like is Tasha's microphone
even on like I don't understand why she
was with winter apart coming but I'm
happy that scary got second yes you guys
know me so well all right I'm so happy
let's see what ginger cut ginger was
three feet y'all know it's between
scarier ginger for sure it's 40 is
laughs because you know damn well I'm
not playing any damn sports anytime soon
this clearly prefers tacos or Bakula
sighs boo boo sighs all day
like people have forced and fights at my
grandma's house where my grandma's house
always in Brevard we're currently rather
marry a rich beardless man or a poor
hairy man here's my question though when
we made this question
rich beardless man does he have the
ability to grow a beard though because
can we pay for a beard since he'll be
rich my original answer was poor hairy
man but I'm gonna go ahead and change it
and say a rich beardless man uh-uh uh-uh
uh-uh you guys know me so well what does
deep in the beard more just what does
buy one y'all know that I'm hella
shallow when it comes to how tall guys
while it is is Frankie an American
Bulldog or a pitbull this is up for
debate cuz a lot of people when they see
me walking they're like nice American
Bulldog but then other people are like
will cross the Shriekers really I don't
mess with pit bulls I think he's a
mixture but I'm gonna go ahead and say
he's an American
Wow it's a tie it's a 52% pitbull I
always I always think that I always say
he's a pitbull you are always talking
about pit bulls and how he's a pit bull
I would love to believe that he's a pit
bull but I think that people will debate
me on this like if you google American
Bulldog and you look at Frankie and then
you google pitbull and you look at
Frankie
he looks closer to American Bulldog but
we're gonna see his mixed use mixed race
if I'm looking to like right on a lease
what kind of dog I have in the apartment
I'm you're right bulldog so I get the
apartment that's not good
don't bully my bully what curly jump off
of a cliff for a million dollars or
would he rather pay a million or so
unclick I would rather pay a million US
on a cliff oh yeah you guys got it right
good job I would I don't even jump into
the deep end of a pool let alone a clip
so good job for knowing me but I would
be shallow enough to buy a cliff and
name it after myself the only one that I
am a little shocked about is that you
guys think I'd like posh like really
Mike well like I don't know what that's
Pasha's movement but but I don't know
where you would even get that I would
like pasta I don't know but I'm happy
you guys got scary cuz yes
she's the only Barbie that I own in my
house somewhere let me know how you guys
are taking my quiz I'm super interested
to see where you think I answer
something completely different
[Music]